هو العلي العظيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول الله تعالى
اقرا وربك الاكرم الذي علم بالقلم
علم الانسان ما لم يعلم كلا ان الانسان
ليطغى ان راه استغنى
ines
contr
‏are
different in the prop
time in
order to understand
this is of course inq
before
chter
in
‏was because was
first
صلى الله عليه وسلم
في جبل النور في غار حراء
سوره العلق
الله سبحانه وتعالى
علم الانسان ما لم يعلم
very
waso propet
سوره المدثر wased
الله سبحانه وتعالى
يا ايها المدثر قم فانذر
[Silence]
لذلك يقول العلماء نبئ
قرا وارسل بالمدثر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اقرا
يا ايها المدثر
beforeه
العلق
سهل
سوره المدثر المزمل
سوره العلق
كلا ان الانسان ليطغى ان راه استغنى ان
الى ربك الرجعه
اقرا بسم ربك الذي خلق why there
but what concerns us here is
the fact that these two are put together
and there is this extremely sharp contr
between the two
because the prophet صلى الله عليه وسلم
دعوه
مكه
ابن القيم رحمه
‏wased
and
shared with those
was comm to
conage
وانذر عشيرتك الاقربين
بني هاشم
لتنذر ام القرى ومن حولها
‏was comm to
people
andes
and fin andth
was to all
انسوا الله سبحانه وتعالى سد قل يا ايها
الناس اني رسول الله اليكم جميعا
sta
خديجه رضي الله عنها ورقه ابن نوفل
ابو بكر الصديق علين ابي طالب
حp
et and
then it becameans
and tribes
then all of me and the neighboring
tribes and the peninsula at
[Silence]
سهل
سوره اقرا من قوله كلا ان الانسان ليطغى
ان راه استغنى
يقول المفسرون
او اجمع المفسرون على ان هذه الايات انزلت
في ابي جهل
وانزلت فيه عندما
هدد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ونهاه عن
الصلاه عند البيت العتيق
وراى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يصلي ساجدا
عند البيت فقال الم انهك عن هذا فانزل
الله
هذه الايات ردا على ابي جهل
ابو جهل
laterيه
[Silence]
دعوه prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
why الله سبحانه وتالى
‏you have
first that was
the way
even beforeysical
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يا ليتني فيها جدعا يا ليتني اكون حيا اذ
يخرجك قومك
قال اومخرجيهم
قال انه لم ياتي رجل قط بمثل ما جئت به
الا عودي
ورقه
people
are going to dri out
الله سبحانه وتالى
ابو جهل
[Silence]
ان
جزء عمار
الله سبحانه وتعالى اذا جاء نصر والفتح
صلى الله عليه وسلم
تبتب
وتب
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
اذا جاء نصر الله والفتح
ابو لهب تبا لكذا جمعتنا
‏could
all go theme of theران and how
it pulls theer takes him in zooms him in
sometimes
him out
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا
صل على